thanks to huge leaps in what developers
are capable of Designing and developing
video games are bigger Bolder and more
beautiful than ever before whether it's
an open world Behemoth like cyberpunk
2077 a fast-paced first-person shooter
like Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 or a
massive multiplayer experience like
fortnite developers are going all out
and so should you the best way to
experience these games is with the
latest and greatest in PC gaming
Hardware so your resolutions can Peak
and your frames per second can soar
giving you the smoothest sharpest and
most comfortable gaming experience to
make sure you have a top tier gaming
experience we've teamed up with gigabyte
auris to give you a crash course in a
few of the most crucial components that
will elevate your PC gaming hardware and
some of the products in its new line
that might be of interest to you whether
you're looking to get a new rig or just
upgrade some key components here's
everything you need to know here we've
got a pre-built PC filled with all the
latest from auris it can play cyberpunk
2077 on ultra settings and with this
monitor it's all in glorious 4K with a
refresh rate that keeps you in the game
let's go through all the key pieces of
hardware and explain exactly why they're
so important when you're gaming
let's start with the motherboard your
motherboard is a crucial part of any PC
build because it facilitates
communication between the various key
components of your PC like the CPU RAM
and GPU and it controls power supply to
them not only that but it's also home to
your PC's bios chip aka the thing that
handles inputs from any external
peripherals you may have plugged in like
your keyboard and mouse when getting a
motherboard it's important to pick one
that can handle the build you're
planning but also is flexible enough to
give you the option to make improvements
in the future like if you want to
overclock your PC you'll want to be able
to easily swap components in and out as
you see fit so it's a good idea to look
for motherboard features that enable
that take the z790 auris master gaming
motherboard for example it features the
easy latch mechanism that lets you
effortlessly place and remove components
such as a graphics card gone are the
days of fiddling with tiny screws or
delicate plastic tabs and the stress
that comes with making upgrades as a
result it also helps that this
motherboard supports the m.2 form factor
so if you're opting for an SSD in your
build it's even more hassle free since
these are smaller thinner and much
easier to slot in and swap out if you're
a little more advanced with your build
the gigabyte Intel 700 series and AMD
am5 series motherboards support Intel
XMP and AMD Expo respectively which
means you'll be able to squeeze out more
power from your Hardware much easier
than before the BIOS has predefined
profiles and you can enable profiles
from a menu just make sure your ddr5
memory is XMP or Expo friendly and
you're good to go as you can probably
tell while motherboards don't directly
impact your gaming performance you can't
game without a good one so it's a really
important purchase now let's take a look
at the graphics card another key
component of any PC build the graphics
card is responsible for sending video
signals to your displays so in the case
of gaming it basically makes sure that
your games actually show up on your
screen looking nice whether it's 2D
Indie Darlings or the latest 3D
Blockbusters with all the ray tracing
and photo realistic Graphics you can
handle your GPU is responsible for
Translating that to the screen the rtx40
series is nvidia's new Cutting Edge line
of graphics cards and they're packed
full of power and features for gamers
and content creators like Ray tracing
and dlss3 which uses AI to create more
frames making your games look better
with the powerful performance of the
rtx40 series it's super important to
consider how to dissipate the heat the
aorus RTX 40 series Master models can
handle all of that and also come
equipped with an LCD monitor so you can
keep an eye on key GPU information in
real time it's super easy to check your
temperature fan and clock speed and even
your total card power with the LCD
monitor if you have the aurus liquid
cooler series and power supply you can
also use the LCD monitor to check in on
how it's performing or you can customize
it your way and add custom text images
and even gifs to make your setup your
own with the RTX 40 series being a
pretty beefy graphics card that requires
a lot of space and power it's important
to make sure it's secure in your build
which is where the anti-sag bracket
comes in this bracket comes with each
gigabyte RTX 40 series air cooled
graphics card and is tailored to work
optimally with them so to recap your
graphics card is what makes your games
look as good as they do so if you want
to play your games looking the best they
can it's important to invest in a card
that can handle even the most demanding
of games we've talked a lot about parts
that sit inside your PC rig so it's time
to chat about another crucial component
your monitor gigabyte has a wide range
of gaming monitors to suit various needs
but if you're interested in gaming on
them you'll want to focus on the 4K
gaming monitors which feature a variety
of Handy features like the black
equalizer 2.0 to make the details in the
darker parts of game world's pop without
changing the overall image and the aim
stabilizer sync which adjusts motion
blur and vsync to improve your game
playing experience so if you're playing
a spooky game like the Callisto protocol
where danger hides in every dark corner
you'll want all the help you can get in
terms of user experience the on-screen
display sidekick lets you use a keyboard
and mouse to tweak settings and
gigabytes built-in KVM on m-series
models means you can connect your
keyboard and mouse directly to the
screen and use a button to switch
between devices if you have multiple
devices on the Go at once say a
dedicated gaming and streaming PC then
you can utilize gigabyte KVM to connect
your mouse and keyboard to multiple
devices including cell phones and
tablets meaning you can swap between
checking in on chat and playing games
with ease it's important to have a
gaming monitor that works for you and
fits in your space but can also be
flexible when necessary the gigabyte M3
2u and m28u arm Edition come with a
sturdy stand that not only declutters
your desk but is able to tilt to swivel
and pivot the screen to make sure it's
at the exact right height and angle that
works for you it's easy to set up and
easy to move your monitor to make sure
it's ergonomic and practical for your
space so that's everything you need to
know about gigabyte auris's products to
help with your brand new pc setup for
more information head over to aoris.com
and we'll see you next time